a digital single market unveiled by the  European Commission in May this year and  sat to be up and running by late 2016  encouraging innovation while at the same  time enforcing zero price discrimination  for consumers a journal brought by  Panama's industry and internal market  committee's reiterates the need for  cross-border delivery and stopping  geo-blocking a restriction of content  based on your vacation any peace voted  in favor of the report on Tuesday with a  final vote by the full house expected in  January next year mamao roba what are  you 47 Europeans from across the  continent were honored in a ceremony at  the Parliament on Wednesday for their  work and wide-ranging efforts in helping  the most disadvantaged tackling  terrorism and promoting LGBT rights one  thing is uniting us today life is a full  of twists and turns and everyone have a  struggle in their life and you today you  are a truly inspiration for me